enfin libre les cinq infirmières et le
médecin bulgares sont rentrés ce matin
dans leur pays cela faisait plus de huit
ans qu'ils étaient détenus en libye
accueillis par leurs familles ils ont
immédiatement été gracié par le
président de l'ue car stéphane gérin
c'est l'airbus de la république
française mais pour les anciens détenus
bulgare c'est surtout l'avion de la
liberté il a décollé de tripoli à l'aube
une poignée d'heures seulement avant le
départ
les infirmières et le médecin on
ignorait encore tout de leur sort
lorsque l'avion se pose à sofia on
oublie la politique
seuls comptent les retrouvailles les
familles attendent ce moment depuis plus
de huit ans elles sont restées en
retrait main dans la main cécilia
sarkozy et la commissaire européenne
benita ferrero waldner
elle était bien sûr du voyage avec
claude guéant
ils ont finalisé à tripoli les derniers
points de cette libération
à l'intérieur de l'aéroport les
infirmières et le médecin ne semblait
toujours pas réalisé qu'il était enfin
libre
je suis heureuse mais c'est très
difficile pour moi aujourd'hui de dire
ce que je ressens
je suis très heureux de me retrouver en
bulgarie
je suis libre je vais enfin pouvoir
penser au futur
moi ce que je veux c'est oublier tout le
passé benita ferrero waldner a rappelé
le fort engagement européen depuis trois
ans elle a aussi souligné l'âpreté des
négociations avec les autorités
libyennes que c'était très très dur au
début mais finalement on a eu gain de
cause
ensemble et ça fait un moment de cheval
le secrétaire général de l'elysée se
rappelle sa première venue en libye avec
cécilia sarkozy
c'était le 12 juillet dernier nous avons
été impressionnés tristesse qui était
celle du visage du rythme et rio tinto
envisage lui de qui rayonnait de mener
un perspective déjà mis leur pays
les infirmières et le médecin ont
ensuite été emmenée dans la résidence du
président bulgare sous les
applaudissements de la population ils
vont maintenant pouvoir se reposer et
profiter de leurs proches